this appears to be a case of a system
working ride Sheriff Cameron says the
motive isn't clear just quite yet but he
painted a picture of a prior
relationship between the deceased gunman
Austin Wyatt Rollins
and he's 17 and the female student who
is 16 she is in intensive care at a
local hospital at this hour fighting for
her life the second shooting victim a 14
year old male student is in stable
condition
the sheriff detailing how this all
unfolded earlier today and the brave
actions of that school resources officer
deputy sheriff Blaine Gaskell PFC Blaine
Gaskell fired at the shooter and what is
described to me is almost simultaneously
the shooter fired
now Gaskell says it'll be further
investigation to determine whether or
not it was his shot that killed the
gunman but the factor remains Bret that
yet again we've had someone opened fire
in one of our schools in 2018 and
Maryland's governor Larry Hogan says
he's outraged that more isn't being done
no parent should ever have to worry
about when they send their kids off in
the morning to school whether they're
gonna come home safely or not and we
need more than prayers I want to thank
these first responders in law
enforcement officer for the job they did
but we need more we've got to take
action hey just for a little context it
was one week ago tomorrow that the
students here at grade Mills High School
behind me walked out in a nationwide
response to the gun violence Brett for
Jenkins in grib Mills Maryland Grif
thanks